ce que je propose c'est qu'on fasse
paxson vérité au fait que des vérités
chacun a le droit de poser une question
à l'un des invités
waouh voilà où il déclare à dos et du
radose voilà il dit voilà il fait une
déclaration les mais il ya des gens là
bas ils doivent voir et ils voient ils
voient ils voient ils voient des détails
nous faire baver voix gilles verdez
iphone gilbert des sur la tène le maire
il croit que c'est le contrôleur des
impôts dans les buffets côté du tout
faits voix gilles verdez mon frère en
contrôleur des impôts mouflets routes
étroites allées alors qu'il courait ces
deux séries vas-y big lots big lots
comme obama et lee a tout honneur à elie
honneur à elie hockey d'octane question
pour elie présent c est lui qui voulait
poser une question wen alors vas-y vie
commence je voulais demander à gad s'il
était prêt à embrasser les pieds frère
tu es devenu chelou avec les pieds moi
je sais pas si j'ai pas une question
j'ai juste un truc à dire à franck
ouhlala c'est en fait ces règlements de
compte
non mais je vais juste faire juste parce
que je n'arrivais pas à le joindre
bazillac en moi mon argent les mecs
alors il ya une prothèse question des
lits bon si tu veux imposer une autre
n'hésite pas quitte à poser qui fascine
il faut déclarer desclaux bistrot à
saint malo lourdingue
mais je voudrais demander à kelly lourd
si elle devait choisir un d'entre nous
pour le confinement en vrai de vrai qui
est l'autre asie si elle avait pu le
monter alors j'étais engendré bien sûr
mais j'ai choisi déjà basées non vous
savez à quel point ma j'aime rigoler
tout pour l'adar cas merci connu style
beaucoup chanté à pas mal mais si je
devais choisir entre le 100 et le riz la
barca et la barca j'ai choisi régal
[Applaudissements]
elle mesure flow duty ya chaque touriste
qui nous a rejoint la zéolithe il est
vrai que la perruque taux qui a une
question mais tu étais une très bonne
question de big flo bravo
17h02 deux minutes
vasile dessins d'olivier apprend la
primaire cad j'ai une question pour jean
michel maire basil raziq
est-ce que tu pour un filet le contact
de son chirurgien je vais me reprendre
je me sers des implants pour la qualif
n'a pas fait au corps non j'étais à moi
ça fait deux ans qu'on parle mais oui
vous adore on avait repéré par un celle
là on a intérêt à cela adacore mecheri
une bonne question date jouaient ce que
tu as une question ferro dazhou vas-y
way phoque dans la date de la saison 2
j'aimerais bien que d'abord d'abord la
saison de l ai écrit donc là j'attends
plus que l'on sortira chez nous à
l'écrit de franck tu sais pas parler ou
quoi franck évidemment immunisé blosne
you lie froch est ce que je serai dans
la saison 2 un petit passage quand même
comme dans la première que tout ce que
tu veux même plusieurs passages situés
merci mon frère on tient franck qu'est
ce que tu as une question puisque c'est
à toi maintenant
monique question ou une déclaration ou
une question une déclaration je voulais
savoir si big flo et oli envisageait
d'arrêter de faire du rap
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas de genk el battar ahmed questions
feront
est-ce que j'ai une question alors moi
je vais maintenant je vais être la
question un peu gnangnan
est ce que le temps prévu de nous faire
kiffer de certifier le public encore de
nombreuses années ou draps non non mais
qu'est ce qu'il ya de si tu me connais
c'est un dauphin free rochard dauphin
gédé qui se sait mais je vous aime trop
donc je peux pas vous mettre dedans
yahoo fera d aller dans dauphin marocain
voilà et et ahmed c'est un dauphin ça
l'amour il faut pas tout [ __ ] dedans
moi je vais vous dire je propose alors
je vais dire oui j'espère j'ai offert
qui fait de nombreuses années après
c'est le public qui décide s'il va
pleuvoir ma gueule et ses 8 tout ça en a
lancé tôt
non mais non voilà c'est le public à qui
décideront alors s'ils n'ont pas moi je
propose composent chacun une question
qui peut nous [ __ ] dans la merde
ah ouais les grands gastambide fait ce
qu'on voulait une question challenge et
médiateur pour les 10 ans ce qui ne veut
démarrer
moi j'en ai une zone à vas-y froch à
quai pour qui à m si la mia un humoriste
[Applaudissements]
franck des sérieux si on oublie qu'on
est à la télé là on fait un peu raide 0d
sérieux la bonne humeur est étranger non
mais ferro tu sais que moi c'est des
questions creton c'est-à-dire de masi
canal non mais signe pas la saison deux
n'ont attaqué t'inquiète pas on a perdu
au lit ajouter alors ahmed
on a dit chacun une question qui nous
fout dans la merde et je veux rester en
france gastambide et je voudrais voir à
ce jeu je le connais je vais te
rappelles vas-y tu vas et viens je vais
répondre
un humoriste pas vu mais alors que
j'aime pas comment genre dans son humour
ou mais comme le web voilà sur toi de
cette merde je vais bien je vais vous
dire il y en a un
franchement je dis la vérité de ce soir
c'est la vérité c'est les dix ans
aujourd'hui la vérité on s'emballe et
qu'on y en a un
très honnêtement il ne fait pas rire
ouais vraiment une fée paris et
humainement humainement franchement
s'énerve à gad elmaleh sans la double à
la réponse si on n'accepte pas le voit
réponse non acceptés franck s'il avait
dit elie calmos travaux de gad est ce
que tu as une question pour [ __ ]
quelqu'un dans la merde elle matin
cervelle ah ouais c'est vrai que ça toi
sur la toile voisinage et je passe mon
tour du rieu c'est une bonne question
base légale pour qui pour toi bon allez
on va se retrouver après la pub
[Musique]
oui des mois dis moi que tu vois ta
question vas-y jalabert il n'y a pas là
oui on dirait que tu es sur france 2 sur
le col mal est là gad elmaleh tome 1 sur
miley on dirait le tour du le gad
elmaleh mon cas alors vas-y malgache
vas-y frérot non juste avoir joué savoir
par rapport à
avi ce qu'en dira tu as ta vie privée
quoi alors
[Musique]
mais non mais faut cesser mon frère où
il va me dire mais si tu donnes combien
toit de pension mais moi je suis pas
mais je suis pas divorcer moi il est fou
c'est pas moi c'est castaldi nice à
castanet il faut connaître ma pré bol
castaldi vient la question de la double
voie
datsyuk dazhou mois d'où vas-y dazhou
c'est pas grave du tout une question une
question pour [ __ ] dans la merde moi
jeanine minutes j'en ai une barbie girl
et ouais c'est la meilleure salle des
fêtes de tpm perd jamais une pour big
flo et oli
j'étais sûr salle est pour nous très
astucieux non non est ce que est ce que
vous avez déjà piqué un artiste dans vos
textes
voilà c'est bien que nous on est là on
est les gens là on est les gentils
durable on savait très de là mais c'est
pas ça que c'est pas ça qui s'est
demandé oui bien sûr qu'on a déjà fait
évidemment un de ceux qui est pas caché
sa meute orelsan on a un peu titillé
oren dans un son un petit peu mais pas
tant des fans aussi
ouais ouais c'est de vous rattraper
c'est une question vas-y vas-y vas-y big
flo vas-y question pour franck
parmi tous les gens qui a qui
participent à cette émission avec lequel
tu oses tu aimerais changer ta carrière
le plus merveilleux qu'elle tu aimerais
le moins et changer ta carrière et ses
jambes et ça ça c'est chaud mais les
chômeurs
loin est elle est magnifique cette
question je propose qu'il y réponde dans
deux minutes y'a deux minutes de pub on
se retrouve juste après franco plq aux
comptes a remis tous les gens qui sont
là ça peut être mathieu coutadeur a tout
de suite il va vous dire pourquoi tout
de suite
gad elmaleh frère sur la tête de ma mère
il a fait 800 km à vélo depuis
l'émission mais si tu fais trop et on
chausse trapes la frère on dirait qu'il
est lyonnais qui passent des tests
physiques sa mère tu vas et tu vas
acheter une maison trois frères tu fais
un test pour la clé pour un bond à
crédit demandé un crédit il me faut
pédaler mais c'est ça alors on avait une
question je suis mélomane et on se dit
toute la vérité
on doit tous se poser une question qui
fait iech voilà et c'est franck
gastambide est ce que tu peux rappeler
ta question est à qui france juste avant
la pause
alors c'est une question très méchante
qui m'a été fait parce qu'au tournoi
avec qui je voudrais échanger ma
carrière avec qui je ne voudrais pas du
tout l'échangé
voilà alors vous étudiez tu dois dire
pourquoi tu d'ailleurs pourquoi est
franc maçon
alors évidemment sans surprise et une
dimension surprise pour des raisons
financières j'adorais changer ma
carrière contre celle de cyril
évidemment on peut et maintenant tu
connais pas les chiffres n'ont
évidemment du nord je préfère ne pas
répondre à la deuxième question doit
obliger voilà et obligeant vas-y vas-y
non mais tu peux dire parce que tu te
sens pas faire cet exercice peut être
bannie oui d'accord alors vraiment sur
une chaîne de jeu me proud to dire que
c'est lui donc je préfère pas répondre
[Rires]
franck est ce que tu as trouvé que la
vanne de kayes rendent était drôle ring
j'ai plutôt ici j'ai plus de gemma
question bien brigade alors oui franck
d'abord franck répondent à la question
des lits alors vas-y
non je n'ai pas trouvé drôle pour être
très honnête j'ai été choqué à mettre on
n'est pas dans du lait de la musique et
les 2,8 y y en a plus moi c'est plus
engagé plus de wii fit a dit qu'à aller
gada une question au ghana une question
intéressante gascon pédales des cheveux
cnss bâtard de big flo bien les chevaux
base légale au pour à m sila
non mais vraiment il faut que tu te
réponde clairement vas-y vas-y est ce
que faire avoir
le corps de cyril avec les plus de
l'ormeau fait quoi avec quoi ils le
cerveau le lala grand hockey ouais à
voir le visage de franck sur le corps de
kelly très honnêtement je préfère avoir
l'esprit de leurs mots avec le cirill
parce que je pourrai bosser avec kelly
allez on continue est question de bâtard
olive oliviero oui mon chéri j'ai une
question pour toi
non mais attendez moi je suis animateur
syrie
ou alors il cloue au lit
oh [ __ ] ah ouais en même temps c'est
facile alors et en plus ça qu'il
souhaite tellement facile chance sur
deux têtes champions 2 alors je vais
dire alors comme c'est toi qui me la
pose je vais dire au lit quand big
plomelin posera kirby clos mais n'aurait
fionie jeudi aux livres tandis que la
reine but lo'jo rigoler mais non mais
c'est pareil c'est comme c'est comme tu
peux tu peux pas c'est comme tu doit se
dire entre ton père et ta mère
bon j'ai pareil la belle réponse tu
pourquoi voilà non mais je vais donner
et en plus tu as mal parlé à franck
gastambide ouais c'est vrai alors plein
question de tarbes à alesi à super besse
gibert dncg lucas damour question il est
exceptionnel je te jure oui il y eu des
amis ou quasiment au tour de la wii si
vous deviez n'en choisir qu'un vous
trouvez n'en garder qu'un ce serait qui
et si vous deviez en virée à autour de
la table sur treki on habite le medgaz
yang est splendide
sans hésitation si je devais en choisir
un mais vraiment sans fin vraiment je
suis obligée de répondre un hasard et
moi et moi il y moi je t'aime énormément
j'ai toujours cru que tu allais me
choisir je suis un peu déçu je suis
obligé de choisir s'est désolé elie
trois mois après midi le truc mais y'a
merzoug blanchard alias bouder qui nous
a rejoint
regardez cette période
est ce que quelqu'un a une question
voient le meilleur dans les questions
les deux meilleurs dois je penser by
chloé franck gastambide franck à saliès
que telle question de tarbes à weave a
jugé jean michel voilà ces deux
questions qu'elle y voilà depuis trois
ans qu'il est là elle se la joue le
célibataire à saintes qui touche à la
fois j'en ai eu un crushpad chroniqueur
où elle habitait ecoute-moi pose moi la
question je la dore magnifique gad
elmaleh moi si j'ai une question pour
gad vas-y vas-y asie après vas-y kenny
d'abord à moitié pardonnée dit tu peux
tout non blague à part j'ai jamais crash
pour aucun chroniqueur aucun invité les
boudeurs n'a pas d'odeur ni comment même
pas bouder rg je l'aimais je laime
d'amour bah oui mais là oui c'était
marrant de les supporter mécontent je me
mettais dans un photomaton les chansons
de lire vous termonde dans un frigo qui
elle est dans un photomaton où il
travaille dans un karting savez
connectés permettent dans un karting
adamus et vraies questions
si vous nous rejoignez on est en direct
sur celui de céder 10 ans tmp cinq
grands groupes sont vides a donc alors
que les je voulais dire un truc à jour
mais vas-y apprendre à laquelle jean
dolly j'ai eu un crash pour personne
attente émission nulle part mais par
contre mon coeur et plis
ouais gad elmaleh est là nous balance
seule folie on va la travailler on sort
mais c'est une question d'âge est une
question moi j'ai une question est
d'abord et à ma table et olly gan j'ai
une question pour toi
vas-y ça fait dix ans tu fais du tour
c'est quand que ça que voit confier une
question si jamais tu vas dit je t'aime
d'amour quand on est comme ça c'est pas
mal ça voulait savoir est ce que est ce
que c'est vrai est ce que cette rumeur
du porno c'est vrai oui
oh la balle et devient même plus c'est
une chanson mais pourquoi j'ai entendu
alors que moi c'était vrai j'ai regardé
sur les ai regardés sur google tout de
suite là les rumeurs sur vous il ya eu
des rumeurs non mais c'est vrai que
cette rumeur mais c'est des conneries
sur franck gastambide as états unis
parce que voilà parce qu est ce qu il
ait d'autres jeunes
on raconte n'importe quoi